okay
[Music]
that is Elise santora talking about the
new musical comedy that will hit Fremont
Street is called Christmas in hell yes
it was a hit off Broadway in New York
City and now they have taken this play
they brought it live to Las Vegas for
the very first time here to tell us
about that is the woman with the moves
Elise santora along with Baku job thank
you both for being here today thank you
for having us this show sounds fun it is
totally fun it's Christmas in hell yes
it's it's um the story basically is a
boy that mistakenly is sent down to Hell
instead of Charles Manson
and as he returns he has changed from
the sweet little boy to a very strange
boy so his father has to go on this
massive journey and to hell
to make a deal with Lucifer and all
kinds of wacky things happen in the
middle of all of those things Christmas
you think Lucifer
this is one of the writers of The
Simpsons right Gary Apple yes TV
animation but Simpsons is his big and we
talk about Lucifer Buck you're the guy
yeah I'm the guy uh saved up all my
cereal box tops I'm thinking that from
the last segment you know hopefully we
can maybe get Wicked Donuts to send us
some stuff than the guy from Hades so uh
it's uh it's a lot of fun you know every
every person grows up wanting to play
the devil of course it's a lot of fun
yeah so uh big shoes to fill hot shoes
to fill but it'll be a lot of fun all
right we have a clip actually yeah are
you playing Lucifer let's take a look
your two little speakers
[Music]
I cannot wait to see this it just looks
like it's irreverent it's fun and is it
fun for all ages it's for the adults
it's funny adults
um and they can choose how old the
children hope to be okay so there's some
material that's some irreverence right
that might have to be yeah I mean so
here's the idea like the the show is fun
for the whole family except for the kids
because there is some language but it's
not coming from a sense of vulgarity
it's coming from the sense of
perpetuating the story if that even
makes sense and I don't even know if I'm
trying to cover that or not
there's something I get what you were
saying yes all right we're actually
locals so what's exciting about this
production is that we're bringing
theater that is more accessible for
those who live in Las Vegas your locals
with Broadway experience we should point
out so this is a top-notch production
absolutely can't wait to see it thank
you both so much for being here
Christmas in Hell starts November 17th
is that right that's right that's
correct through January 15th just go to
the notoriety Theater which is at 450
Fremont Street go to Christmas and
hell.com to get tickets for more
information